su médico realizará el desbridamiento
quirúrgico para extirpar el tejido
muerto del interior y alrededor de su
herida
las heridas pueden producirse por
diversas razones tales como lesiones
quemaduras escaras también llamadas
úlceras por presión o úlceras de
decúbito e incisiones quirúrgicas
infectadas
los tejidos Muertos dañados o
contaminados pueden poner en peligro la
circulación hacia la herida además los
tejidos enfermos son propensos a la
infección
los tejidos muertos provocan el
crecimiento de bacterias que compiten
con las células de crecimiento para
obtener nutrientes e interfieren con el
proceso de cicatrización los tejidos
sanos de la herida pueden infectarse
la infección puede convertirse en una
bolsa de pus llamada absceso que impide
la cicatrización de las heridas
una herida como resultado de una
quemadura puede formar una costra
endurecida de tejido muerto llamada Es
cara que puede evitar el crecimiento de
tejidos sano y la cicatrización
antes de su procedimiento su médico
adormecerá el área alrededor de su
herida con anestesia local para un
desbridamiento más amplio usted recibirá
anestesia general
para empezar su médico puede utilizar
soluciones Salinas o desinfectantes para
lavar o irrigar su herida
luego su médico evaluará la profundidad
de la herida
revisando el alcance del tejido muerto
su médico puede quitar el borde de los
tejidos de alrededor de la herida para
generar un margen limpio de tejido sano
y mejorar la cicatrización
al final de su procedimiento su médico
le colocará Una venda seca en su herida
a fin de controlar cualquier sangrado él
o ella también puede cubrir la herida
con gasa húmeda para estimular la
cicatrización
[Música]
después de su procedimiento usted deberá
seguir las indicaciones de cuidado de la
herida con mucho cuidado asegúrese de
proteger su herida de cualquier golpe y
mantener la herida y las gasas limpias y
secas